た
[音楽]
おおおおおお
いい
皆さんこんにちはやろうと申します
最後の嘉田氏のスパートで少し緊張は右翼する
なんだから
実は今回の低いバージョンの中で月僕が長崎出身なんですね
この中でアナ雪出身を語って雲海
でしょうか
を
もう無かっていらっしゃいます
感謝木々州では今回が小差
ありがとうございます
叶えるテーマが質問やなかっ派
こうも協会賞に4
お身体の中から生まれでそう中を合わせで演奏しました
ん
大学進学を機に部分 a で今東京で働いているんですが
東京出されるというねやっぱり長崎ガス切れ
魂はなぜ金を入れ住むで巣立っ版ん
簡単に防具の自己紹介をすると今
東京にあるルイーズというサーヴァンプの企業経営をしておりまして
その与えパーティアシさんという自由をやっています
これは全国に750名いる女につながる
死亡初めておしゃれたちが企業様の代わりに様々な渓流を妹で来校するというサービス
です
言うなら何か号されて公言したい南部ので
それは喪失なんですか形になっているそんなようにしれます
本以下はあ
このデート日総長崎言いも提案し綾部られる
長瀬に架けるファンえーみなさん
むげでお話入れろ
最初もお伝えしたいこととしては
今回は無しじゃないわ
素晴らしい優勢がでも
突拍子前や3件
何か凄い戸籍を染めたそんな話じゃないです
なぜ冬前提案するぞと僕が皆さんに仕上げ
早く社会でで少し投げ合わ経験つれ車
その短い人生の流れ何を考えてい
その経過何を警護官が
但しも合わせの青年の知恵を共有いえばと思っています
今回お話したい内容は努力と計算 g です
努力と経済について
そじやま市で可能で高校以来の話です
この中であさき東高校の出身ながら
養おう
思いますねー
さらにてくる use
僕もあるだけにこの日にあるなぜ交互にが入りました
僕は者焼香地雷女も今日も何もない
人間がたですね
著者ラファエルミーバースいただく形も皆さんの流れ
工房即有些大学卒業者
女もヤりたいああなってやって夢合う人があるから
イタチないは当時の僕はもうすごく羨ましい感じであるです
そのぐらい南3-8位だよな
2006年4月東高校に入学した分
当時今でもはっきりと覚えているんですよ
クルーズ揚げ物アンケートだったんですよ
自分住むスピードを変えるとき神暮らしに入りたいですかぁて分ける
選択肢は3つ
希望する希望しないどちらで御用意し
僕はこちらで泳いをやりました
k パティスな暗さ自分のいっしょなく
ずっと悩みました高校生は同走していました
そのに自分が進むクラスでさえん
たり人間を出してしまうようなそんな食欲いかに命でした
そこから大学進学を機に5分 a
大学を卒業して it オンオンザリーン場所に入りました
ん
どのような会社はというと当分は書を一望できるような実態が敵将のん
ビルに os があって
いややはり心配たちはもうすごく仕事ができて a
マリスもの
スムーズな影
今磯で時間がすねーよなぁ
その発表車
今でねそのしたら双喜亭リーチャーなぁとやっぱり映画あるんですよ
毎日びしっこすると聞いている人たちに流れ
僕は設け
上下色がも違う
2ずを受けませんあっはい
ソン先輩に言われるの時間です
あっ浜でもすごい恥ずかしくて
ただしグレー
仕事について入れる
9本はだべ車
東栄店はと berry さん
会社の名節には
なんとなくこの会社いいかなとか考えてない理由
明治精一杯だとは高玉現実に合ったサービス内容で2たた問題から誰も泣かれてしまっ
たら
希高校生の時代のアンケートをお願いしました
よろしくお願いしましたん
一生懸命働きましたら
ただなんかうまくかみ合わないはず今
長い犯的な気がして
入社して
2か月後ん技術に会社を植えることを決めました
4ガールズのが理由です
特にやる事ないんだよ
方に入りましたーーー
1か月でぐらい教えました
妄想させましたん
漫画うようになり英語サイン
barbie 一切入上がった感動を聞いていないと
1回そもそもはそれでアンジェ人生の夏休みでした
一家離散見つけられ味んすよ
まったく良いんじゃねぇ
あれでその1番を待ってる中でも知りました
長崎なゲームながらもうかなえばですね
このなんとなく働いて
なんとは為替レ
なんかですねえ
なんか安心でいいかな
今現在
イオン e 想像できる将来
新車時ぐらいがすごく嫌だった
そのテキストを入れたんです
何が大きく変化をする隊員は例えば
今回はかかりそうなんだと奇妙にやめだと決めた時のに何か傷版者とじゃないかと
たぼ意外という女
高校卒業して東京いる梅ラボはすごくイングをキャラッ
なんとなく頑張っていただけ
何かボーベー者という経験は基地の中
1社目の会社を言われた kk でそれは証明されてお願いします
大きく変化した意味合いは今喫茶んすぎる
できることがないんであれば
その現実を芸名で
今何をやればいい銀さんするよ
何ができる形ではなく何をやりたいかと
それ今まで積み上げてきたこともへ
まあいる件
これからもとも行ったりすればそれ
今
今この木はも僕がないようにやりたい
考えました
その時は分散は新しい者槐歳
自分の価値を試したい
言わなかったことを見なさい医者私も5歳
そうのでスターバップで雪に住む事を決めました
二山しましたん
今ではニーズという会社の経営ドバーチャルヘアーシーサーと事業を通して人手不足に
悩むチリソー起業家
細田事故で大学ワークを希望する方達も
シーンをやっています
世の中に何かにをしたいそう思ってチャレンジをしています
といえば
2019年7月13日
本日ここまで動くなら意味なんですが
彼氏や事業を通してチャレンジしていることもそれがつながってこのテープに出させて
いただいていることに
ん
皆さんに最後は
ただ小説家
ただ旅行さ
ダビエアダメなんじゃないかな
何か多く会大の狙えば
例えば
僕が
僕ねー
多くの場合
高校卒業したら東京に行こうとあっ
このバイブでこういう経験積んだば
海上じゃねぇ
スターバックやろ
そういう小さな時には大きな樹山があっていま
ここがここに良いということです
僕は信じています
努力の次はさやなくて切っさんが人生を変える
損を
キラーン
チーム位 loop
することで奪われることもあるそう
多くの人は
なんと強くに言われている
そこに人生の大事な力つ使う
努力をする場所を決めてない
多くの人は努力さえすれば人生が貢献するだろう
そう思ってます
僕は棋士会グループは必要ない努力をするなというイメージを伝えたいわけじゃない
です
努力狭いに計算しましょう
その次が山目
自分の小さなしたが目標がができるを
それが人生なるお呼ばれし
災害に
導入を急い
決断をする
何が難しい仕事ではありません
自分という1人らは何者方でどういういつもの主人公だしたら
次の2ページはどうぞ o
昨日は何し明日ば錦織はそんな楽しいねるっ
ただそのぺーよう幅からとビッグ方やめてください
小さなグラン文がためが小さなの言葉でで
そして小さな仕方生まれ
それだが gaa できない
なり望みなら t になる必要があるんです
5分
あなたも最近
何勘違いしますから
視聴ありがとうござい